صعب للغايه ان تجلس وحيدا بعد سنين طوال
من الدراسه والتعليم المتواصل في مثل هذه
الغرفه مع كتب وكراسات تذكر بالماضي
المفقود كما تقول مارينا الطالبه الجامعيه
التي منعتها طالبان في مرسومها الجديد
بمنع الاناث من التعليل
الفتيات كنت ادرس للامتحان النهائي غدا
اغلقت الكتاب وخابت جميع اعمالي يظهر وزير
التعليم العالي الرجل الاول في ملف منع
الفتيات من الدراسه على شاشه التلفزيون
ليقدم التبريرات قديمه جديده في مقدمتها
استمرار الاختلاط بين الطالبات والطلاب
والمساس بين الجنسين لم يكن حسب التوجيهات
المقدمه الى الدارسين والدارسات
طقس في معظم الجامعات لم تنتهي عمليه
الاختلاط بين الذكور والاناث بعد وهذه
قضيه لا تجيذها الشريعه البته
لقرار طالبان بحرمان الفتيات من التعليم
فقد استقال من جامعات مختلفه حكوميه
واهليه ما يقارب من 50 من الاساتذه
الجامعيين في وقت يضرب عدد من الطلاب في
جامعات عده عن الحضور للدراسه فيها
طالبا تبرر قرارها والطالبات يرفضنا
ويطالبنا بازاله العقبات الامنيه
والاقتصاديه والتعليميه لا ان يتم القضاء
على تعليمهن كما يجب تقليم الاظافر اذا
طالت وليس قطع الاصابع بحسب تعبيرهم عبد
لنادر العربيه كابول